well the modern american idea was our
tribe right and we're doing our best to
to move beyond historical race even
religion um ideas of of tribe and so
so
we're
trying to overcome um
what may be innate but is certainly
historical tribalism and a dei within a
corporation in my estimation is asking
us to redraw those lines at least in
terms of identity but i think it's
pushing us even beyond identity cohesion
groups and that kind of thing um it's
asking us to re-tribalize and it's no
surprise to me then that you would say
it's making corporate environments worse
not better
yeah so i mean the the basic point that
diversity training doesn't work at least
doesn't work as intended is not original
with me i mean there's a very famous
article at harvard business review
just a few years back it was after 2012
i know that looked at all of these
diversity training programs and found
that the majority of them didn't do
anything and if i recall correctly some
of them made things substantially worse
and i don't think that's much of a
surprise because the default assumption
of the dei sector is that this is a
deeply racist society based on
false inputs like the scores on implicit
associations tests for example or the
idiotic definition of anything that
involves any gap in performance as being
racist
so
the things that dei programs tend to
suggest for example um a lot of the
exercises from privileged walking to
listing the stereotypes for
other populations so on these might be
useful if you were actually dealing with
entrenched bigots that had not
previously encountered one another much
but the reality again is that in modern
society only about eight percent of
people i really i think that figure's
correct are strong bigots
so in fact what you're doing is taking a
bunch of basically non-racist people
many of whom if you're in the academy or
you're in an elite business are better
trained and educated than you are by the
way looking at the typical dei
consultant and you're telling them all
this stuff that's focused on constantly
seeing race and it's focused more
importantly on
associating every minor aggression you
encounter with racism and it's not
really a surprise that that backfires i
mean
the microaggression trainings that i've
been sent online or that i've just read
through as a businessman
are almost unbelievable i mean they're
things like uh if someone mispronounces
your name that may well be racist and it
probably isn't accidental with the
assumption being i guess that black or
asian employees should be ready to
experience this harm and fight back
brutally against it and so on the
reality is that people get their names
mispronounced all the time uh one of my
good friends is a caucasian named joe
wohowski
and i think i just pronounced that
mispronounced that there actually
and there's generally no racial
implication to it at all but if you
consistently tell people this kind of
thing like you've barely escaped the
plantation this abuse is constant a
common phrase is don't think you
imagined it don't think you didn't see
it of course you're going to create
these hyper-sensitive trigger-happy
people and that's not really what any
sane business would want but i will tell
you there's kind of an anti-virtuous
cycle here because if you create those
hyper-sensitive trigger-happy people
they're going to come up with an endless
supply of mostly imaginary racial
grievances and where are they going to
go to hr to the dei office
for the full podcast go to
foxnewspodcast.com